a london library sparked a little bit of
backlash thankfully
after hiring recently an
anti-racist carnival troupe with a
performer who dressed up as a monkey
a monkey in a rainbow monkey costume
with a gigantic
plastic phallus hanging between his legs
for a children's reading event the
monkey
had a giant plastic sex toy
in the shape of a phallus hanging
between his rainbow clothing
that he swung around for children at a
library
the red bridge central library
in the united kingdom hosted a
performance from the mandinga
arts carnival group anti-racist sexual
revolutionary
video footage on social media shows the
guy with the giant
floppy creepy mock genitalia this is
part of the summer reading challenge
in partnership with the world wildlife
fund for a very special nature themed
challenge
that will inspire you to stand up for
the planet so they said
i'll i think it would be good in the
united kingdom and the united states
it's not long before this craziness
comes here
i think it would be good to ban this
sort of stuff
to not permit it to limit the free
marketplace of ideas to exclude
rainbow monkeys with sex toys between
their legs dancing for kids i think that
would be
i don't think that the mandinga giant
dancing rainbow monkey sex toy group is
one of the quote blessings of liberty
as some erstwhile conservative
commentators have suggested
i don't think this is what the founding
fathers had in mind i don't think that
there is a first amendment protection
for flopping sex toys around for little
children
i really like the idea of standards and
it worries me that people
are pretending to get exercised about
some radical right wingers
who have relatively small followings who
have
relatively little influence in the
country and they make a big deal and
they cut them off from all aspects of
society
when this kind of stuff is not only
permitted
but celebrated encouraged and subsidized
by taxpayers in this case
in the united kingdom but we've seen
lots of similar things here in the
united states
and there's all of the evidence pointing
that it will only get worse
that's a big problem that's i think
something we should focus on
hold up i'm glad you like that clip you
can get the whole episode on this
youtube channel it's called culture wars
the phantom menace
you can also get it on apple podcast
stitch your google play spotify myspace
xanga live journal all over the place
you can also
get my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds thank you for sending
this book to the top of the best seller
lists
even if the lib bestseller lists don't
want to acknowledge it we'll see you
next time